bonsoir ce mercredi au conseil des
ministres le garde des sceaux robert
badinter présentait son projet de
réforme du code pénal c'était là son
dernier geste de ministre de la justice
tout un symbole monsieur badinter était
nommé quelques heures plus tard par le
chef de l'état président du conseil
constitutionnel
près de cinq ans au ministère de la
justice c'est presque un record s'achève
avec hervé brusini nous avons retenu
quelques temps forts j'ai l'honneur au
nom du gouvernement de la république de
demander à l'assemblée nationale
l'abolition de la peine de mort en
france
une simple phrase un moment historique
pour robert badinter l'aboutissement
d'un contrat moral passé avec lui-même
mais aussi avec le pays
l'abolition de la peine capitale était
la 109e propositions du candidat
mitterrand
mais ce jour là la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale le ministre
badinter c'est une dernière fois la
place à l'avocat faillible aussi
terrible aussi odieux que soient leurs
actes ils les points comme en cette
terre dont la culpabilité soit totale
et puis bah protestation à soumission et
syndicats de policiers des chauffeurs de
taxi une cible unique
le garde des sceaux dénoncé comme seuls
responsables de la mort d'agents des
forces de l'ordre badinter laxiste dans
les prisons pourtant il n'y a plus assez
de cellules pour les détenus ils sont
plus de quarante quatre mille mais 85
printemps de la révolte carcéral
face à elle cet autre prison l'autre
détention proposée par robert badinter
fini les quartiers de haute sécurité à
présent des télévisions des parloirs
libre les studios pour accueillir les
familles et pourquoi pas même supprimer
l'incarcération
c'est l'institution des travaux
d'intérêt général sans oublier les
victimes et leur indemnisation
tout cela en attendant le projet du
garde des sceaux la réforme du code
pénal napoléonien plus de quatre années
de travail
une sorte de grand oeuvre pour robert
badinter adopté par le gouvernement le
jour même où il quitte ce bureau